in the Ramsey Solutions Lobby David and
Emily are with us hey guys how are you
great then
welcome welcome where y'all from
Indianapolis Indiana uh welcome to
Nashville and you're here to do a
debt-free screen yeah yeah I'm fun and
how much have you paid off
we paid off forty five thousand ninety
dollars and seventy two cents and how
long did that take twelve months in six
days Wow and your range of income during
that year not much at the beginning but
will end about seventy-five cool what do
y'all do for a living I'm a registered
nurse and I own I'm a landscaper own my
own business okay very cool very good so
what kind of debt was the forty five
thousand what did you people buy an
education for her my student Oh the
nursing degree okay yeah alright so we
gave Sallie Mae her walking papers oh
yeah you gotta get eviction you're out
of here old lady
absolutely so fun and so what started
this twelve months ago well go back to
when I was 18 a friend of mine gave me
your book Total Money Makeover and I was
like well that's that's nice and good
thing to shut up good thing show a cup
of coffee almost exactly it was a good
conversation piece and so when I was 21
I ended up buying a business a
landscaping business for on contract for
five hundred and ninety three thousand
dollars and that was I ran it for a year
and a half or so and I wouldn't breathe
I couldn't I was working just like a dog
and I just I couldn't go anywhere and
ended up selling the business back to
the original owner which worked out
great and the day before we got married
and so I started over Wow right right
when we got married and so we then the
first eight months of our marriage we
were surviving and a lot of thanks mom
and dad for free meals and and but then
when we started the debt snowball for
sure was right when she got her
a full-time nursing job and then my
business when I reached the Wii when I
restarted it started to really pick up
and how long have you been married two
years to five years okay so you went
through a year and a half and then you
really kicked in and decide to do this
and that's at the point you got your
nursing job yeah so were you or you've
taken your boards and graduating or
something or what yeah I was still in
school and we got married so at the
first semester we were just passed
arriving like he said and then once we
got once I got my job we hit full
throttle on the that snowball okay cool
so you kind of knew what you wanted to
do and but you just had to get the
incomes lined up and then you went after
it yeah yeah yeah and so you did that
just based on that book on the coffee
table or what yeah and a couple bootleg
CDs from your financial piece class
we've bought a lot of books from you
since then so I feel so much better the
copyright police will be putting you in
handcuffs I'm glad you got the help yeah
what I hear here is that you guys I
don't know maybe 10 20 grand a year
before the license or whatever and then
you started making more seventy or what
I think you said 70 right 75 or 75 and
so what happened was you knew you had to
clean some mess up and so you've already
proven to yourself that you can live on
whatever that was before you just stayed
there is what really want it yeah yeah
talk to folks about that you had the
money you could have increased Leif's
lifestyle but you didn't you just have
to say no learn to say no what is that
no like what people you just say that
it's hard watching you know your friends
and people our age getting new houses
new cars I'm still driving the same car
I got when I was 16 so you just have to
say no it leaks three different kinds of
fluids we still live in an apartment
we're saving we're now saving up for a
down payment on a house and so that's
just gonna be there our next next thing
but yeah very cool very cool so what do
you tell people the secret to get
out of debt is saying no I think
believing in the vision that your life
how your life will look different if you
don't have debt don't believe that and
then everything else will fall into
place and also the budget budget
sticking to the budget Sookie yeah
absolutely you know you can say no if
you have those two things if you if you
have a belief that it's gonna be better
it's worth the sacrifice when I live
like no one else so later I can live and
give like no one else and if I got a
plan so that's very insightful very well
said good job you guys way to go proud
of you how do you feel
oh it's absolutely amazing you know we
have a like $30 used to you know a $30
experience would stress us out and now
it's like oh what it doesn't even matter
yeah well you got to spend the week in
Nashville yeah absolutely all right
David and Emily Indianapolis Indiana
$45,000 paid off in 12 months making
75,000 a year count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
that's how it's done right there well
done you guys man that's awesome
congratulations very proud of you hey
we've got a copy of Chris Hogan's book
for Tyra inspired for you signed by him
because that's the next chapter now
becoming very wealthy and giving a bunch
of it away then that's where you're
headed
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income on a $500,000 in common